SPEAKER 1: to Get
Cooking in Cloud,
where we shared the best recipes
to apply in your cloud kitchen,
I'm Priyanka Vergadia.
And in this episode, we will
talk about scaling a web
application on Google
Compute Engine.
As we learned in our
Compute Engine example,
when web apps are
deployed on GCE instances,
deployment and scaling
is done automatically
and seamlessly by using
instants templates.
When your website
becomes popular,
and the users integral
from 1 to 1 million,
you need to add instances.
And when the requests
go back down,
you need to remove
those instances
to keep the costs low.
But how does adding and removing
instances automatically work?
Compute Engine
autoscaling policies.
Autoscaling is one of the
features of managed instance
groups.
Managed instance groups allow
you to operate applications
on multiple identical
virtual machines based
on instance templates.
You can make your workload
scalable and highly available
by taking advantage of
automated managed instance group
services, including
autoscaling, autohealing,
regional deployments,
and auto-updating.
But wait.
What is an instance template?
An instance template is
a specific, customized
configuration of
the GCE instance
that facilitates the reuse
of instance configurations
by using managed
instance groups.
This custom image then
becomes the starting point
for future deployments.
Now, back to
autoscaling policies.
Autoscaling policies provides
a way to add or remove
instances as needed.
The impact of autoscaling
policies is twofold.
One, your users get
a great experience
using your application
because there are always
enough resources
to meet the demand.
And two.
You maintain better
control over your costs
because the autoscaler removes
the instances when demand falls
below a specific threshold.
To create an
autoscaler, you must
specify the autoscaling policy
and a target utilization level
that the autoscaler
uses to determine
when to scale the group.
You can choose to scale using
average CPU utilization,
Stackdriver monitoring
metrics, or HTTP load balancing
serving capacity, which can
be based on either utilization
or requests per second.
The autoscaler continuously
collects usage information
based on the policy, compares
the actual utilization
to your desired
target utilization,
and determines if the group
needs to be scaled up or down.
For example, if you scale
based on CPU utilization,
you can set your target
utilization level at 80%,
and the autoscaler will
pull for the CPU utilization
and check if it
is more than 80%.
If so, it adds the new
instance to the instance group.
If the CPU utilization
is less than 80%,
then it removes an
instance from the group,
making sure the capacity
is always maintained.
You can use autoscaling in
conjunction with load balancing
by setting up an autoscaler
that scales based
on the load of your instances.
For example, assume
the load balancing
serving capacity of a
managed instance group
is defined as 100 requests
per second, for instance.
If you create an autoscaler
with HTTP load balancing policy
and set it to maintain a target
utilization level of 80%,
the autoscaler will
add or remove instances
from a managed instance
group to maintain
80% of the serving capacity,
or 80 requests per second
per instance.
Now, our architecture needs
to automatically replace
instances that have failed
or have become unavailable.
And when the new
instance comes online,
it should understand
its role in the system.
It should configure
itself automatically.
And it should discover
any of the dependencies.
And it should start handling
requests automatically.
To replace a field
instance automatically,
we can use several Compute
Engine components together.
You could create
instance templates
that use a public image
and a startup script
to prepare the instance
after it starts running.
But we recommend that you
use deterministic instance
templates, which minimizes
risks and unexpected behavior
from your instance templates.
Thanks to Managed
Instance Groups,
now we have a system that can
replace unhealthy instances
with new ones.
But we still have a challenge.
How are we going to know
which instance to replace?
Well for that, we need to define
what is an unhealthy instance.
And to do that, we
use health checks.
We recommend that you use
separate health checks for load
balancing and for autohealing
Autohealing health
checks are set up at the
managed instance group level.
You create a health check that
looks for a response on port 80
and that can tolerate
some failure before it
marks instance as
unhealthy and causes
them to be [INAUDIBLE] created.
In this example, an instance
is marked as healthy
if it returns
successfully two times.
It is marked as unhealthy if
it returns unsuccessful three
consecutive times.
We learned some tricks to
make your web application
resilient by spinning
up new instances
and taking them down if
compute resources fail
or your traffic grows.
That's all for today on
Get Cooking in Cloud.
Here's hoping you can
whip up something great.
Join us next time where we will
see a journey of the startup
from a few users to
thousands of users,
and how they evolved
their web application
architecture to meet the
growing and changing needs.
If you like this
video, then check out
the previous episodes too.
And to see more
such content, don't
forget to like and
subscribe to our channel.